All right,
so last time we did something I think substantially harder than anything we've
done in the class.
So far.
We looked at mixed strategies and in particular we looked at mixed strategy
equilibrium,
right?
And there was a big idea last time.
The big idea was if a player is playing a mixed strategy equilibrium,
then every pure strategy in the mix,
that's to say every pure strategy on which they placed in positive weights must
also be a best response to what the other side is doing.
And then we use that trick.
We used it in this game here to help us find Nash Equilibria.
And the way we helped it,
the way it allowed us to find nasty but I bra is,
we knew that if in this case Venus Williams is mixing between left and right,
it must be this case that our payoff is equal to that of rights.
And we use that to find Serenas mix.
And conversely,
since we knew that Serena is mixing,
but Ken Between Little Alan Liddle,
ah,
we knew she must be in different between little Allen at La and we use that to
find Venus is mixed.
So I want to get back to this example just for a few moments just to make one
more point and then we'll move on.
But we'll still be talking about mixed strategies throughout today.
So this was the mix that we've found before we changed the payoffs.
We found that Venus's equilibrium mix was 0.7 0.3 and three is equilibrium mix
was 0.64 and a reasonable question at this point would be how do we know that's
really an equilibrium,
right?
We kind of found it but we didn't kind of go back and check.
So I want to do now is actually do that missing step.
We rushed it at last time.
Just want to get thrown out of material.
Let's actually check that.
In fact p star is a best response to Q star.
So what I want to do is I want to check
that Venus is,
makes peace star is a best response for Venus against Serena's makes Qstar and
the way I'm going to do that is I'm going to look at payoffs that Venus gets.
Now she knows she's right.
Now we know she's playing against Q star.
All right,
so let's look at Venus is pay offs.
I'm going to figure out how,
how payoffs for al her payoffs for our,
I'd also her pay off what she's actually doing.
P Star.
All right,
so Venus is payoffs.
If she chooses l against Q star,
then she gets stolen.
It's what we had on the board last week.
But now I'm going to put in what Q star is explicitly.
She gets 50 times.
Point six
is Q star and this is one minus Q star.
She just gets 50 times 0.6 and AC times one minus 0.6 which is 0.4 AC times 0.4.
All right,
and we can work this out and I worked it out at home,
but if somebody has a calculator that can please check me.
Uh,
I think this comes to 0.62.
All right,
I'm going to just check that.
All right.
And if Venus chose right when they're right here means shooting to Serenas right
to Serena's forehand.
If she chose rights,
then her pay offs are 90 queue starts and 90.6 plus 21 minus Q starts at 20.4
so 98.6 plus 20.4 and again,
I worked that out at home and fortunately that also comes out at 0.62.
All right,
so what's Venus is pay off the piece star.
We've got high payoff for both our PR strategies.
So her pay off from actually choosing peace dollar is what?
Well,
p Star is 0.7 so 0.7 of the time she would actually be playing left and when she
plays left,
she'll get a pay off of 0.62 and
three of the time,
0.3 of the time she'll be playing,
right.
And once again she'll get,
you can't get paid off of 0.62 and do I have a calculator?
Yes.
Sorry.
Thank you.
So ps p star is 0.7 I'm,
yes,
you're actually right.
So this is p Star and one minus P.
Stop.
All right,
so let's,
let's,
let's make that clearer.
I sure what the equilibrium is but p stone itself is point stuff.
Thank you.
All right,
so in vias plays,
plays left with property 0.7 that 0.7 the time she'll get an expected payoff of
0.62 and 0.3 of the time she'll get them to pay off again a 0.62 and that's the
kind of math I don't have to do at home.
That's going to come out at 0.62 again,
assuming my math is correct.
All right,
it's all I've really done here is confirm what we did early last time.
We knew that we in fact shows Serena's mix queue to make Venus in difference
between left and right.
And that's exactly what we found here.
Getting going laugh gets points 0.6 to go going right,
it gets a 0.62 and hence piece star gets 0.62 but I claim we can now see
something a little bit a little bit else.
We can now ask the question is p Star?
In fact,
our best response,
while for it not to be a best response for this not to be an equilibrium,
there would have to be some deviation that Venus could make that would make us
strictly better off.
Let me repeat that.
If this were not an equilibrium,
there would have to be some deviation for Venus that would make her strictly
better off.
Right?
By playing p Star,
she's getting a return of 0.62 so one thing she could deviate too is playing
left all the time.
If she deviates to playing left all the time,
her pay office still 0.62 so she's not strictly better off.
That's not a strictly profitable deviation,
right?
Another thing she could deviate too,
if she could deviate to playing rights.
If you deviate to playing,
writes her pay off will be 0.62 once again,
she's not strictly better off just the same as she was before.
So that's not a stripy profitable deviation.
All right,
so what have I shown so far?
I've shown that piece star is as good as playing left and p stars as good as
paying right about now.
That's how he constructed it.
So deviating to left is not a strictly profitable deviation and deviating to
rights.
It's not a strictly proper profitable deviation.
But at this point somebody might ask him,
say,
okay,
you shown me that there's no way to deviate to a pure strategy in a strictly
profitable way.
But how about deviating to another mixed strategy?
All right,
so we're so far we've shown,
we've shown just to up here,
we can see that Venus has no strictly profitable
pure strategy deviation.
Your strategy
deviation.
She has no strict portables,
pure strategy creation,
cause each of our PR strategies yield the same payoff as did her piece of meat
mixed rap sheet.
Uh,
you have the same as p Star,
but how do we know that she doesn't have a mixed strategy that would be strictly
batter?
How do we know that?
Anybody,
how do we know that?
No,
no,
no.
Hands going.
Oh,
it was,
it was a hand up.
Good.
Good mix between left and right will still yield 0.62 good,
good.
So any mix,
any mixed venous deviates too will be a mix between left and right and any mix
between left and rights will be a mix between points six to 1.62 and hence will
yield 0.62 all right,
so we're going to use,
again this fact we developed last week.
The fact we developed last week was that any mixed strategy yields a payoff.
That is a weighted average of the pure strategy pay offs.
The payoff to the pure strategies in the mix,
any mix strategy yields a payoff that is a weighted average of the payoff to the
pure straps in the mix.
That was our key fact last week.
So here,
if we've shown that there's no pure strategy deviation that's strictly
profitable,
then the con be any mixed strategy deviation that stripey profitable.
Why?
Because the mixed strategy variations must yield pay offs that lie among the
pure strategy deviations.
Right?
So this is a great fact for us.
What does it,
what's the lesson here?
The lesson is
we only ever have to check
for strictly profitable
pure strategy
deviations.
That's a good job.
Why?
Because if we had to check for mixed strategy,
deviation is one by one,
we'd be here all night because there's an infinite number of possible mixed
traffic deviations.
All right,
but the ultimately pure strategy do you guys do you have to check it.
It's just repeat the idea.
Suppose suppose that isn't any pure strategy vacation that's profitable.
Then the Colby,
any mixed strategy deviation that's profitable because the met the highest,
the highest expected return you could ever get from a mixed strategy is one of
the pure scratches in the mix and you've already checked that none of those are
profitable.
All right,
so this simple idea,
it's an idea we developed last time.
Not only helps us to find Nash Equilibria,
but also to check for Nash Equilibrium.
All right?
Now a lot of people I gathered from feedback from sections were left pretty
confused last time.
It's a hard idea.
Actually.
I looked at the tape over the weekend,
you know,
I can see it.
I could see where it can be confusing,
but it's actually I think what's really confusing.
Hey it wasn't so much I think this,
no it wasn't too much that I could have been clearer.
I'm sure I could have been.
It's this is really a hard idea,
this idea of make strategies.
So we're going to work on it again today,
but I think one of the ideas that gets people confused,
it's the following idea.
They say,
look,
we found venuses equilibrium mix,
my choosing a p and one minus P to make Serena and different and we found
Serena's equilibrium makes by finding a Q and a one minus Q like Venus and
difference.
And a natural question you hit people ask then is why is Venus quotes trying to
make Serena in difference and why is Serena quote trying to Venus and different
and that's not really the point here.
It isn't that Venus is trying to make Serena and difference.
It's that in equilibrium she is going to make 300 different actions.
It doesn't have goal in life to make Serena and different between left and
right.
And it isn't Serena's goal in life to make Venus and different between left and
But in equilibrium it ends up that they make each other in different.
Alright.
And the way that we can see that is that if Venus puts something you said last
time,
it's repeated.
If Venus puts too much weights,
more than 0.7 on the left,
on left,
then Serena,
Serena,
just chiefs to left all the time.
And that can't possibly be an equal number.
And if Venus puts too much weight on right,
then Serena cheats to the right all the time.
And that can't be an equilibrium.
So it has to be that what Venus is doing is going to make story.
No,
exactly.
And different and vice versa.
Yeah.
All right.
Now let's see that idea in some other applications.
Just talk about this a bit before we move on.
All right,
so it turns out that some very natural applications for mixed strategy,
whatever.
Yeah.
Or rise in Games and sports.
All right.
So let's talk about a few now.
Ah,
can I,
yeah.
Can anybody suggest some other places where we see randomisation or it's mixed
strategy?
End Equilibria in sporting events.
Okay.
Let me,
let me actually grab the mic myself.
So come out of it.
Anybody?
Anybody here?
Uh,
and I know we hit anybody here to play football.
For example.
I'm going to fucking American football now.
Gridiron game.
Not,
not the civilized vapor,
right?
I don't play it.
Yes.
Just don't you play football,
right?
So,
so where is the mixing?
Where's the mixing involved in playing football?
Where an equilibrium where we expect to see mixed strategies.
Yeah.
There's somebody down that be come and get them.
All right.
So shout it out.
Running game and passing game.
All right.
The running game in the passing game,
right?
So very simple idea whether to run or whether the past when you have the ball is
likely to end up as a mixed strategy equilibrium.
The defense is also randomizing between,
for example,
rushing the pasta or playing a run defense.
That right.
This is not exactly a game.
I know a lot about it,
but I'm hoping I'm getting close enough here.
Right,
right.
It couldn't possibly be a pure strategy equilibrium,
right?
Other than very extreme parts of the game,
like at the end of the game perhaps.
But for most of the game,
it's very unlikely to end up as a pure strategy equilibrium.
Much more likely that the office is mixing between passing and running.
And for that matter,
between going into the left,
going to the right and going to the center.
And uh,
the defense is awesome mixing between,
uh,
over it's types of defense.
All right?
So we see that those people who are watching guests today,
we see that in football games.
All right,
why don't we see it in sport?
So other sports,
I can't have a room full of non sports fans.
How many of you ever watch any sport?
It's let's raise raising hands here.
All right.
Some of you do.
All right,
so this is,
this is baseball playoff season,
right?
Right.
How many of you been watching the baseball playoffs?
Raise your hands and watching the baseball past.
Can we,
I,
I'll let you off.
And I knew she'd been doing my homework.
How many of you were watching the playoffs and sped,
how many watch the Yankees game last night,
right?
Quite a few of you.
All right.
So there hadn't been very exciting yet,
but we hope against gonna get more exciting.
Right?
So what is,
what do you do when you're watching baseball?
What kind of things do you see where you just know that the must be mixed
strategies involved in must be randomisation involved.
Now I've got a few more hands on.
Good.
So you start choosing how to pitch the ball,
choosing how to pitch the book,
Go and enlarge a little bit more.
So,
but more fast ball versus slider versus change up all sorts of,
all right,
so there's different ways of throwing the ball.
All right?
And there's going to be randomization from the picture or this doesn't look like
there's randomization,
uh,
by the pitcher over whether to throw a fastball or a curve ball or whatever.
How has the hitter randomizing that?
Okay.
How's the hit of randomizing?
Cause it hit her.
Randomizing it.
Oh,
what's the head of doing?
What?
While this is going on?
Anybody?
Yeah.
He's choosing whether to swing or not to swing.
Oh,
he's okay.
He's choosing what to swing or not to swing or they'll put it on what you can do
that just after the ball thrown.
Right.
So you sometimes hear the commentators say that that guy that hit her was
looking for a fast balls.
That right.
We're looking for a curve ball.
That hit is trying to anticipate the pitch.
Is that right?
There's not a game I played a lot of either.
I'd be a little bit right.
Your financial and you're trying to anticipate where the ball is going to be
thrown.
Okay,
so the type of bullying throw in baseball and the way in which the,
the,
the pitch being anticipated by the header is lightly.
We make strategy.
What else is likely to be mix strategy in baseball?
What else?
Anybody here on the Yale baseball team.
Ah,
okay.
Okay.
I've got one.
I've got one volunteer here.
All right.
All right,
so what else?
I mean a stand up a second that says let's have a baseball team member.
All right.
What's your name and where do you play your picture?
Okay.
He's not gonna give them based on notes he's looking at,
I'm going to ask this.
Suppose you did get on base,
which is or no,
we've got an amazing,
I dunno.
Let's assume that's the thing that happened is right,
right.
Well,
what might you ran into mind that you're standing on base.
What might you randomize about whether the steal second or not right where the
just steal them or whether they're trying to steal them on it.
It's to have a second.
Second.
All right,
so the decision,
what is trying to steal a nod is,
is likely to end up being random.
Right?
And if you're the picture,
if you're the picture,
what can you do in response to that?
But here's a picture,
right?
What can you do in response to that?
Either choose to try to pick them off or not.
All right,
what else can,
the one thing you can try and pick them off with us to be quicker and quicker to
the plate?
What else you can pitch out.
What else?
Hm.
At least those three things.
Right?
And these,
those three things.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
Hey,
I have an expert here.
I'm bad.
I had an expert.
All right.
So in this case,
in this case,
we can see there's randomisation going on from the,
from the run I,
whether he,
whether he attempts to steal the base or not,
and by the picture or whether he throws the pitch out or whether he tries to
throw it to get to the plate faster.
All right.
Okay.
So we see this in sport,
we don't see it well anticipated by sports commentators.
I mean,
give this put down a second.
So in baseball for example,
you'll sometimes,
he seemed quite sophisticated statistical analyses of baseball in which somebody
will have looked at base stealers,
are across the majorly use,
and they'll look at all the instances in which a player was on first base and
having in a position where you think they might steal and a look at what
happened on every attempt to steal,
whether they were in fact caught stealing or not.
All right?
And they'll try and measure the value of these things.
And you'll see the conclusion not come to something like this.
They'll conclude that whether the guy stolen or whether the guy has attempted to
steal an op,
sorry,
or whether just sat in first base doesn't seem to make much difference.
I'll say I was,
I think the payoff for it,
for you,
for even great base.
There's I've attempting to steal or not.
All right.
When you take into account the pickoffs,
uh,
versus just staying put,
turns out the payoff in terms of the impact on the game is Rafa equal.
And then they'll draw that.
These analysts will then draw the following conclusion.
They'll say,
oh,
look,
speedo,
the ability to steal basis is therefore overrated in baseball.
How have they made a mistake?
What's the mistake?
They made that,
all right.
So the premise was,
let's give them the premise.
The premise was that when a base stealer is attempting to steal at art,
the expected return in terms of outcome of the game is roughly equal.
Whether they attempt to steal or don't attempt to steal the conclusion is
therefore,
stealing doesn't seem such a big deal.
What's the mistake they've made?
Yeah.
Let me borrow it again.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Hit your hat.
And the pitcher has to react differently and pitching when he knows that there's
a fast guy on.
Good.
So I'll pitch a has to rectify.
It's talked about petro again,
right?
So one thing got picture stayed was he wants to get to the plate faster,
Right.
What does that mean?
Getting to the pipe foster,
let's just means just shout it out.
People going,
hey,
you getting the ball to the catcher as fast as possible so that he has the best
chance to throw out the runner.
Right,
right.
So you're gonna,
you're gonna pitch from what's,
you're not gonna do that funny wound up thing,
right?
You're going to thank you.
Got a pitch from the stretch.
I knew it was a term that some way I'm noting American by hate being here.
Right.
And you're more likely to throw a fastball,
right?
There's not,
there's some advantage and throwing a fastball rather than the curve ball.
All right.
Both of what?
Both.
Both actions of which both having to move more towards hospitals and pitching to
the stretch are actually costly.
For the Pitcher,
but we'll get there in a second.
Let's just back up a second so then that was good.
That's right,
but it just back up a second.
The premise of these commentators was what it was that the return to stealing,
attempting to steal seems to be roughly a wash.
It seems to me that the expected return when this quite based on our team,
Mr this a base is roughly the same as the return when they don't attempt to
steal a base,
but I claim we knew that was going to be the case.
We didn't have to go and look at the data.
Why do we know that was going to be the case?
Gosh,
how do we know that the,
that you were bound to find a return
in that analysis that finds those things roughly equal.
Wow.
Yeah,
just do one or the other.
Good.
Excellent.
Since we're in a mixed strategy equilibrium,
since she's randomizing,
it must be the case that the returns are equal.
All right.
I might look for right off the big idea here.
Right with it.
That's the thing we learned last time.
If this player and he's a professional baseball,
by US doing this,
they've been very well trained.
Lot of money has been spent on getting the tactics right.
All right,
let's,
there's people sitting there who are paid to get the tactics,
right?
Right.
If it was the case that the return to base stealing wasn't roughly equal,
when you attempt to steal or didn't attempt to steal,
right,
then you shouldn't be randomizing.
Since you all are randomizing,
it must be the case that the returns are roughly equal.
All right,
so that's the first thing to observe and the second thing to observe is what we
just pointed out.
I in fact,
the,
the value of having a fast base speed on the team doesn't show up in the
expected return on the occasions on which he attempts to steal or which he does
not attempt to steal.
It shows up where it shows up in the fact that the pitching team changes their
behavior to make it harder for this guy to steal by going faster to the plate or
throwing more fastballs.
And where will that show up on the statistics?
If you're just a statistician like me,
you just look at the data.
Where will that show up?
It's supposed I can't keep track of every single page.
I don't connect to observe all these basketballs.
Well I see the effect of all these extra fastballs and pitching from the stretch
in the data.
Somebody,
it's going to show up in the batting average of the guy who's hitting behind the
base stealer.
The can I using behind the base dealer is going to have a higher batting average
cause he's going to get more pictures,
which are fast balls to head and more pitches out of the stretch.
If you ignore that effect,
you're going to be in trouble.
But we knew we handle as this properly using gain through,
we know where to make snapchat equilibrium.
We know in facts the pitching team must be reacting to it.
We know that must be a cost in doing that and the cost turns up in the head or
behind.
So when you're watching the playoffs and the,
and the north node,
no,
now I'm giving you permission to work with,
which were the TV at night after I've done my homework assignments.
All right.
But before anyone else's homework assignment,
you can have a look at these,
uh,
these baseball games and have a go at being a little bit better than the
commentators who are,
who are working on.
All right.
So one application for Ihc strategies is in sport,
but not the only application.
Let's just talk about another application or slightly more scary application.
So often nine,
11,
there was a lot of talk in the u s about the placement of a baggage checking
machines at airports.
All right.
Actually it's still going on at all,
but there was a lot of talk then about the placement of machines to search the
luggage that goes on.
That goes on board.
The hand luggage was being searched anyway,
but to search luggage going into the cabins.
Right.
And it was pointed out,
and at the time,
this has changed since the word,
actually enough machines in the u s uh,
the day after nine 11 to search every single bag that went into the hole and
you'd hear discussions of the following type,
you'd hear these experts on,
um,
uh,
Nightline or whatever,
and they'd say,
look,
there's no point trying to do this because if we put all our baggage searching
machines at Logan Airport in Boston,
for example,
then the terrorists will simply move their attack to O'Hare.
And if we put them on her hair,
then they'll move their attack to Logan.
If we put there,
we have enough to do both Logan and her hair,
then they'll move their attack to some third airport.
Right?
So th th th there was a sense of doing in the,
I was kind of a depressing time anyway,
it ends and do in the air saying that when you,
if you put your,
uh,
your,
baggage searching machines somewhere,
all you do is caused the attempted a terrorists terrorist attempting to block
the planes to go elsewhere.
And you hear the same things today.
About searching individuals as they go on the plane.
For example,
you hear discussion that says,
if we only search,
uh,
main traveling alone and let's say,
then you'll quickly,
uh,
end up with all the people carrying bombs being capitals or women,
right?
And again,
there's this sense of doom,
the sense that says it's hopeless.
Wherever we do that,
what that's going to force the terrorist to do something else.
We wouldn't have gained anything.
So once again,
that's wrong,
right?
What's wrong about that one?
What,
what should we be doing in that sense?
Maybe you come,
come down again.
And what should we be?
Just what,
what should they have done if they did do with those luggage,
baggage,
uh,
searching machines when they were in short supply after nine 11.
And what do they do with searching people as they get on planes?
Why haven't they didn't do,
they didn't just put them at certain airports and announced they're just at
these apples.
Right.
That would have been the crazy thing to do.
That would have been hopeless.
Tiny,
hopeless,
but not,
not why's,
what should they have done?
What did they do?
Anybody want a gas?
Yeah.
In namely randomized who they were checking.
Right?
Right.
So when they're checking passengers,
they're gonna randomly check passengers.
Right when they're checking.
When I think about the baggage machine,
there's a sensible thing to do is to put a big metal box that every app ports
and say,
we're not going to tell you which of these boxes actually have,
uh,
have,
have baggage checking machines,
which effectively is randomizing right from the point of view of the terrorists.
They don't,
they're not going to know where the,
where the baggage checks are going on.
Alright.
That's worth doing.
It doesn't,
it doesn't get a perfectly eliminates.
Well unfortunately it hasn't probably going to perfectly eliminate all terrorist
attacks,
but it does make it harder for the terrorists.
Alright,
so randomisation there,
whether it's literally randomizing over who is checked or whether it's as it
were,
randomizing by concealing,
we're in fact,
you have placed those machines can be very effective.
The hard thing both in sports and in these military examples is really mimicking
randomization.
It's very hard for us as humans to do it.
And there's a famous story about a military commander,
actually an English metric,
Amanda during an insurgent war in I think it was Malaysia,
uh,
I think it was laser after World War Two,
where again,
he had to worry about randomizing which convoys to protect and the way in which
he,
uh,
he figured out the randomizing it was the right thing to do to try and protect
these convoys as well as he could with small numbers of,
of troops.
And the way in which he randomize was he literally randomized every morning you
put a bit of paper in his hand and he had,
somebody had one of his sergeants pick which hand the peanut butter paper was
there.
All right.
So we do actually see these random strategies used.
The reason we have to literally randomized it's cause it's very difficult to do
so unless you're a professional sports player.
Okay.
But it turns out that mixed strategy equilibria and mix strategies in general
are relevant beyond just these contexts in which you think of people literally
around.
Amazing.
And I want to look at a different context now.
All right.
So I want to go back to a game we started a few weeks ago.
Uh,
this isn't the same game.
It's a sequel.
It's a followup in our exciting adventure of our dating couple in the classroom.
Who were our dating couples?
We still have them here.
That was the guy who is,
who is the,
yeah.
There they are.
Their,
they even sitting closer.
I want to success here.
Alright.
Can we get the camera on them or seconds?
I start up a second.
Uh,
yeah.
Sign up for a second sentence.
Thank you.
And your name was Chad to just repeat it yet.
David?
Yeah.
Can you actually go and look at this?
Does this romantic of what David and I and your name is?
Nina.
Nina and David.
Okay.
And I think,
I think we just,
I think we've pretty much figured out last time that Nina's player one and
David's plan to that,
right?
That's right.
And that,
yeah,
I just remember last time,
well,
I'll pick on you in a second.
You can sit down and say,
all right.
So we'd figured out last time they were trying to go on a date and they were,
they hit a range to go to the movies.
They out a two and half,
three movies,
but two that remains viable.
And the problem was being typical economics majors.
Who are you both economics majors.
I think they can pick that out.
They all look at that.
So being typical economics majors,
just hopeless it dating,
they'd forgotten to tell each other which movie they're going to so that you
know that that works.
I don't know if that worked out well on not,
but now then life has moved on.
They're going to try it again.
But this time taking advantage of fall in,
in New England,
rather than go to a movie,
they've decided on some new activities.
So they might either go apple picking
or they might go to the Yale Rep.
All right.
Whoops.
Rap War Rep and see a play.
All right.
And uh,
so apple picking is,
has its advantages and the full,
whether it's local flavor,
it's uh,
uh,
you know,
it has certain,
uh,
undertones about the garden of Eden or something.
It hasn't yet.
I don't know if we can use the term flavor local,
otherwise we're doing American apples,
but that's all right.
And the Yale Rep,
you know,
Europe is a good thing to do in new haven.
Go to a play.
But I think it's Richard.
The second is showing now is that it put on a great date play.
But you know,
economists are trying to show they have culture.
So,
uh,
you know,
there it goes.
And,
uh,
it's just thing the payoff.
Sir.
I like this
as they were before,
where by we mean Nina wants to meet David.
Uh,
but she would,
you know,
give him the choice.
You'd rather meet David,
uh,
in the apple feels all right.
And,
uh,
David,
who's a,
who's a dark personality,
likes the sort of darker side of Shakespeare and,
uh,
he would,
he also wants to meet Nina,
but he would rather meet at the Yale Rad.
All right.
I don't know if that's backwards.
I apologize to that preference.
It's all right.
All right.
Um,
but once again,
because they're still in competent economics majors,
they've again forgotten to tell each other where they're going.
Yeah.
All right.
I forgot to tell each other where they're going.
So let's analyze this game again.
We figured out this was a coordination game last time,
ah,
or several weeks ago and we know in this game we know what the pure strategy,
national whatever.
All right,
so no prizes be able to spot them.
Uh,
one of the Nash Equilibria and pure strategies,
let's put this in pure strategist.
So one of the pure strategy Nash Equilibrium Equilibria is for them both to go
apple picking and meet up in the bishop tortured or whatever.
And another pure strategy equilibrium Islam both to choose the wreck.
All right?
And we'd figured out that if they were able to communicate,
there's really a pretty good chance of the managing to coordinate that one of
these equilibria bots we suspect.
I think that this is not all that's going on here.
It looks quite likely that come your next Saturday afternoon when we send these
guys out on that date,
they're going to fail to meet.
It's at least plausible.
Right?
And to test the plausible.
Is it that,
let's ask them,
have you been,
have you managed to meet on a date yet?
They know,
no,
haven't managed to be today.
See you.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm proving the point.
I'm proving the point that in fact they haven't managed to create this
coordinated equilibrium yet.
All right.
So it's,
it seems at least plausible that they going to fail to coordinate his plausible
that going to fail to coordinate.
And we'd like to sort of capture that idea.
And the way we're going to capture that idea is,
let's see if there's another Ricola bourbon this game.
Well,
the certainly isn't.
Another pure strategy equilibrium in this game is that we know that.
So if there's another equilibrium,
it better me mixed.
So let's try and find
a mixed
nash equilibrium in this game.
And remember this game is called Battle of the sexes.
That's a famous game.
This is battle of the sexes revisited.
Alright,
so how are we going to go about finding this mixed Nash equilibrium again?
What we'll,
we'll,
we'll interpret it later but let's just work on finding it.
So in particular I'm going to post like the idea that Nina is going to mix p one
minus p and David is going to make Hugh one minus Q.
So how do we go about finding David's equilibrium mix Q one minus Q.
What's our trick from last week?
She got a cold call at this point but it's not half to how am I going to find
cue the equilibrium queue.
Somebody
now.
Thank you.
Use Venus.
Is Payoffs good?
Good,
good.
So to fine isn't Venus's payoffs.
It's Nina's payoffs.
Okay,
fair enough to defined,
sorry to find the Nash equilibrium cue to find the mix that David's using.
We use Minas payoffs,
use Minas payoffs.
All right,
so let's do that.
so in particular for Nina,
if she goes apple picking then her pay off is to with problems.
He Q if she meets David and zero otherwise
and if she goes to the rep then have pay off is one.
If she meets David.
Uh,
sorry.
That's what I to be careful it's got again,
it,
she gets the Rep.
How is zero?
If David goes apple picking with property Q and a payoff is one if she meets
David at the rep,
which happens with probability one minus Q.
That correct.
Alright,
so this is the payoff from apple picking and this is her pay off from seeing
Richard the second.
And what do we know if Nina was indeed mixing,
what do we know about,
what do we know about these two payoffs?
They must be equal,
right?
If Nina is in fact mixing,
then these two things must be equal.
And that means what?
What we're seeing is two Q equals one,
one minus Q or
Q equals,
uh,
them,
two thirds I guess it is.
No,
it's one third.
Sorry,
one sec.
One Sec.
Sorry.
That right.
Here's one third.
Okay.
So our guests is that if there's a mixed strategy equilibrium,
it must be the case that David is assigning a property,
a third to going apple picking,
which means he's assigning prevalency two thirds to his more favorite activity,
which is going to see Richard the second
right.
What about,
I'm going to hold these both down.
Okay.
How do we find Nina's mix?
All right,
so to find,
yeah,
defined the Nash equilibrium p to find Nina's mix.
What do we do?
What's the trick?
Somebody use David's payoffs,
these David's payoffs.
So David's payoffs.
If he goes apple picking,
then he gets a payoff of one if he meets Nina that and zero.
Otherwise,
if he goes to the rep,
he gets a pay off off zero.
If Nina has gone apple picking and he gets a pay off of too,
if he meets Nina at the Rep.
All right.
And once again,
if David is indifferent,
it must be these are equal.
So if these are,
if they,
it is in fact mixing between apple picking and going to the Rep.
It must be that these two are equal.
And if we set this out carefully,
we'll get a,
we'll get one p equals to one minus
which is p equals two thirds and one minus p
equals one third.
So here we have Nina assigning two thirds to going apple picking,
which in fact is her more favored thing and one third to going to the Rep.
All right.
Okay,
so we just use the same trick as last time.
Let's check that this is in fact an equilibrium.
All right,
so in particular,
let's check that it is in fact an equilibrium for Nina to choose two thirds,
one shirt.
All right,
let's check.
It's a check that p equals two thirds is in facts.
The best response
for Nina,
let's go back to Nina's payoffs for Nina.
If she chose to go apple packing,
her pay off now is two times Q but Q is equal to third
plus zero one minus one minus Q.
And if she shows this chooses to go to the rep that her pay off is zero with
problems in your third and one with prophecy.
Now two thirds organize.
I've taken the lines I had before and substitute it in now what we know it must
be the correct Q and one minus Q
and this gives her a pay off of two thirds in either case.
All right,
if she chooses p a pay off to p
will be two thirds of the time she'll get the payoff from apple packing,
which is two thirds and one third of the time she'll get the payoff from going
to the rep,
which is two thirds
for a total of two thirds.
All right?
So Nina's payoff from either her pure strategies is two thirds.
Her pay off from our claimed equilibrium.
Mixed strategy is two thirds.
So neither of her possible pure strategy deviations were profitable and then
lose anything either,
but they weren't profitable.
And by the lesson we started the class with,
that means it cannot be any strictly profitable mixed deviation either.
So indeed for Nina,
p is a best response to queue,
right?
Well,
we can do the same for David,
but that's not bothered.
It's symmetric,
isn't that?
All right?
So in this game we've found another equilibrium.
The other equilibrium.
The new equilibrium is Nina mixed,
two thirds,
one third and David mixed one third,
two thirds
and we also know the payoff from this equilibrium.
The equilibrium for this pay off the both players was two thirds.
There are three caliber in this game.
They managed to meet an apple picking,
in which case the payoffs are two and one they managed to meet at the wrap.
That's the pure as the second pure strategy equilibrium,
in which case the payoff.
So one and two or they mix both.
The mix in this way and their pay are two thirds.
Two thirds.
That's
right.
Why is the payoff so bad in this mixed strategy equilibrium?
Everyone agree?
This is a pretty lousy pay off,
right?
The other equilibrium pay off.
The worst you've got was one and if someone's got to,
but now he you are playing at a different equilibrium and this different
equilibrium,
you're only getting two thirds.
Wait,
why are you only get to what happened?
Why is the payoffs got pushed down so far?
What's happening to our poor hapless couple or not happens?
I don't know
what's happening to our capital.
Yeah,
ash.
Okay.
Relevant.
Yeah.
Sometimes they don't meet that failing to meet.
Right.
The reason what's,
what's forcing these payoffs down is they're not missing very often.
How often are they actually meeting?
How often are they meeting?
Let's have a look.
Let's go back to the previous
bored.
Here it is.
Alright,
so they meet when they end up in this box or this box.
Is that right?
All right.
So what's the promise you of them ending up in those boxes?
Well,
ending up in this box is prevalency two thirds,
one third,
and ending up in this box is probably the one third,
two thirds.
Is that right?
You're up,
you end up meeting apple picking the two thirds of the time when Nina goes there
times the one third of the time when David goes there and you end up meeting at
the rep,
the one third of the time Nina goes to that at times,
but two thirds of the time that David goes that,
all right,
so this is the total prevalency of meeting.
This is the privacy of meeting
and it's equal to
uh,
four nines,
four nines.
That's fine.
All right,
so four ninths of the time they're missing,
but five ninths of the time and more than half the time,
more than half the time they're scoring up and failing to meet.
This is why I call them hopeless dating couple.
Right?
All right.
So this is a very bad equilibrium,
but it captures something which is true about the game.
What is surely true about this gay is that if they just played this game,
they wouldn't meet all the time.
In fact,
what we're arguing here is that meet the rest of them half of the time.
All right?
But certainly this idea that we're given from the pure strategy Culebra but they
would magically always managed to meet it seems rather unlikely.
So this does seem to add a little bit of realism to this analysis of the game.
However,
it leads to a bit of an interpretation problem.
You might ask the question,
why on earth are they randomizing in this way?
Why are they doing this?
It's bad for everybody.
All right,
and this leads us to think about a second interpretation for what we think mixed
strategy equilibrium rather than thinking of them literally as randomizing.
It's probably better in this case to think about the following idea.
We need to think about David's mixture as being a statement about what Nina
believes David's going to do.
David Been,
we literally randomizing but his mixture.
Q one minus Q we could think of as mean as belief about what David's going to
do.
And conversely,
Nina may not literally be randomizing,
but her p one minus p we could think of as David's belief about what Nina is
going to do
and what we've done is we found the beliefs,
we found the beliefs such that these players are exactly in different over what
they do.
We found the beliefs for,
for David over what Nina is going to do such that David doesn't really quite
know what to do and we found the beliefs Nina holds about what David's going to
do,
something he doesn't quite know what to do.
That makes sense.
All right,
so it's probably better here to think about this,
not as people literally randomizing,
but these mixed strategies being a statement about what people believe in
equilibrium.
All right,
we'll come back and look at this game some more later on to are our couple,
I'm afraid I don't quite out of the woods yet,
but I want to spend the rest of the day looking at a yet another interpretation
of mixed strategy equilibrium.
So far we have to,
we have PPO that people are literally randomizing.
We have thinking of these as expressions about what people believe in
equilibrium rather than what they're literally.
And now I'm going to give you a third interpretation.
So for now we can get rid of the Venus and Serena game.
So to motivate this third idea,
I wanted to think about tax audits.
All right?
So none of you here have ever probably ever had to pull out a tax form except
for the fact that the lot of parents in the room today,
is it parents weekend?
And that was going on.
All right.
So what are the parents from and where you want to wave your arms and the
outdoor parent here?
Yeah.
Okay.
So at least these guys are probably someone in their life filled out a tax form.
All right.
All right,
so come tax day up.
The parents and the Roman face a choice and the choice is are they going to
honestly fill out their taxes or are they going to cheat?
I'm not going to ask them what they do.
Well,
maybe I will,
but for now I would ask them what they did.
All right.
And
so they can choose one of two things.
They can choose to pay their taxes.
Honestly,
we'll call it h or to cheat.
This is the tax payer.
The parents.
All right?
And at the same time,
the audit office,
the auditor can,
it has,
it has to make a choice.
And the auditor's choice is whether to audit you or not.
This is not literally true because literally the auditor can wait til your tax
return is,
comes in and then decide whether an audit you all right,
but for now,
let's think of these choices being made,
some multi Nestle and we'll see why that makes it more interesting.
Yeah.
All right,
so let me put down some payoffs down then I'll explain them.
So two zero four minus ten four zero zero four.
All right,
so how do we interpret this?
Let's look at the auditor's payoffs first of all.
So the auditor is very happy not having to audit your parents and having your
own,
your parents pay taxes.
So we'll get that a power for four and it'll turn out in this game and we'll,
we've decided,
uh,
in the payoffs did the auditor is equally happy if she actually audit to your
parents in the year that they cheated.
All right.
And we'll get the,
we'll say that makes the auditor equally happy.
All right.
Now the auditor is not so happy if she audit your parents when they're honest,
because auditor costly.
All right.
And,
uh,
the auditor is really unhappy if she fails to audit when the parents cheated.
All right,
let's look at the I wanting parents.
I'm parents,
let's call them taxpayers.
All right?
So the,
for the taxpayers,
what are their payoffs will normalize things.
So if they're honest,
will give them a payoff of zero.
All right,
let me say correctly,
fill in their tax form and pay what they're supposed to pay.
But if they can feel some of the income or they pretend to have a whatever it
is,
a third child,
all right?
All right,
then,
then they might be in trouble.
If they audited,
if they're audited,
they're going to have to pay a big fine,
maybe even go to jail.
That's minus 10 course.
If they're not audited,
they get to keep a chunk of money as well.
Call out for
all right?
Everyone was down.
But the basic idea of this game,
right?
In reality,
we could add more complications if you think of different ways to cheat on your
taxes.
But I don't want to give tutorials and how to cheat your tax on.
She did her taxes here.
All right.
So it's not going to take a long staring at this gay man to figure out that
there are no pure strategy equilibrium in this game.
Lets us do that.
So from the taxpayer's point of view,
if they're going to be audited,
then they'd rather pay their taxes than not.
And if they're not going to be audited,
then according to these payoffs,
they'd rather cheat.
All right?
Um,
from the auditor's point of view,
if they knew everyone was going to pay taxes,
then if they wouldn't bother auditing,
and if they knew it almost on a cheat,
then they'd off bought it.
All right?
So you can quickly see that there's no box in which the best responses coincide.
There's no pure Strachan Nash equilibrium.
All right?
Well those people who I think who this is seeming otherworldly,
uh,
you will have to pay toxic taxes and a couple of years and trust me,
your parents are paying taxes now.
All right?
So what we want to do here is we're going to solve out and find a mixed strategy
equilibrium,
but we're going to give it a different interpretation to the Internet.
The Equilibria we've found so far.
But the basic initial exercise is what we're going to find that we're going to
try and find the equilibrium here.
So find the Nash equilibrium here.
We know it's going to be mixed.
All right?
So to find the probability with which tax payers pay their taxes and have you
already start getting ahead of myself and to say to find the proportion of tax
payers who are going to pay their taxes,
what do we do?
What must be,
what must be true of that equilibrium proportion queue of tax payers who pay
their taxes?
How am I going to find that cute shout out somebody.
Yeah,
look at the auditor's payoffs.
All right,
so from the auditor's point of view,
if the auditor audits,
their payoff is to Q plus four one minus Q,
and if they don't audit,
that payoff is for Q plus zero
one minus Q.
All right,
I want to say I did this.
This is too cute for one minus Q four Q zero one minus Q.
And if indeed the auditor is mixing,
then these must be equal.
Ms Must be equal.
And if they're equal as us do a little bit of Algebra here and we'll find that
two Q equals four one minus Q,
right?
So whew.
Uh,
equals a boom two thirds that right.
Four of us,
yes.
Two thirds
cubicles to feds.
All right,
so our claim is to make the auditor exactly indifferent between whether to audit
or not.
It must be the case that two thirds of the parents of the parents of the kids in
the room are going to be paying.
They're paying their taxes honestly,
which is a third aren't just going to worry.
And if my mind,
all right,
let's have a look at the taxpayer to find,
to find,
sorry,
I'm sorry.
We found the taxpayer.
We found the proportion of taxpayers who are paying the taxes.
Now I want to find out the problems of being audited.
How do I figure out the equilibrium probability of being audited in this model?
How do workout the equilibrium privacy of being audited,
shout it out.
Equilibrium publicly being audited.
I going to use p and one minus piece of it's gonna be the property of being
audited.
How do I find p?
Yeah,
I mean,
look at the tax payers pay offs from the taxpayer's point of view.
If the tax payer pays their taxes,
that pay off is just zero.
And if that,
and if they cheat,
their payoff is minus 10
p
plus four
one minus p.
All right.
And if indeed the taxpayers are mixing or another saying that is not all
taxpayers are cheating and not all tax payers are honestly paying their taxes,
then these must be equal.
So if these are equal,
I'm going to get four p equals
no it doesn't.
I'm gonna get four equals 14 psi again,
four equals 14 peer requiring four equals 14 p which is the same as saying p
equals two sevens.
Someone can just check my Algebra and that's right.
That's right.
All right,
so my claim is that the equilibrium here is for two thirds of the taxpayers to
pay their taxes and for the audit,
for the auditor to audit two sevenths of the time.
All right.
Now we could go back in here and we could check.
I could do,
I get before I could plug the p's and q's in here and check that.
In fact,
this isn't equilibrium,
but trust me that I've done that.
All right,
trust me that it's okay.
Okay,
so here we have an equilibrium as just write down what it is from the auditor's
point of view,
it is that they audit two sevenths of the time or two sevenths of the population
and from the tax payer's point of view,
it's if they pay their taxes,
honestly two thirds of the time and not otherwise.
All right.
Now,
without focusing too much on these exact numbers for a second,
I want to focus first for a minute on how do we interpret this mixed strategy
equilibrium,
right?
So for the point of view of the auditor,
we're really back where we were before with a base stealer or the person who
search searching baggage on the act at the airports.
We could think of the officer literally as randomizing.
All right?
In fact,
there's some truth to that.
It actually is the case by law that the auditor's literally have to random acts.
All right,
so this two seven,
five,
seven is,
this has the same interpretation as we had before.
This is really a randomization,
right?
But there's two thirds.
One third has a different interpretation and a potentially exciting
interpretation.
It isn't that we think that your parents get to tax day,
work out what their taxes would be and then toss a coin.
Right?
Wow.
They made me do that.
I'm looking at the parents and I don't think that's what they're doing.
Right.
The interpretation here is that the parents,
some parents are paying the taxes and some parents aren't paying the taxes.
There's a lot of parents out there,
a lot of potential taxpayers in the population in equilibrium.
If these numbers were true,
two thirds of parents will be paying their taxes and one third would be
cheating.
So this is a,
a randomization by a player,
and this is a mixture in the population.
The new interpretation here is we could think of the MEC strategy,
not as players randomizing it,
but as I mix in a large population in which some people are doing one thing and
the other group are doing the other,
it's a proportion of people paying taxes.
Alright,
so I don't know if there's two thirds.
One third is an accurate number for the U S it's probably not very far off
actually for if Leah,
I'm to say that number,
that number,
people to pay taxes is more like 40% maybe even lower.
Now.
Uh,
and there are countries I think where it gets as high as 90% I think the US rate
when they end up auditing is a little higher than this,
but not much.
All right.
Okay.
So again,
we're going to think of this not as randomization,
but as a prediction of the proportion of American tax payers who are going to
pay their taxes.
All right?
Now I want to use this example in the time we have left to actually think about
a policy experiment.
All right,
so let's put this off somewhere.
We can see it.
Yeah.
And let's think about a new tax policy.
Just oppose that.
Congress gets fed up with all these newspaper reports about how two thirds of
Americans don't pay their taxes or whatever,
whatever the true report.
Do you think it's actually a little higher than that one in mind?
They get put up with all these reports and they say,
this isn't fair.
We should make people pay their taxes.
So we're going to change the law and instead of paying,
instead of being in jail for slipping in jail for 10 years,
or their colons are fine of of minus 10 if you're caught,
she's saying,
we're going to raise the fine all the time in jail so that it's now minus 20% so
the policy experiments is
let's raise the fine,
find the cheating.
So minus 20 and the aim of this policy is to try to determine cheating,
right?
Right.
It seems a plausible thing for government.
Want to want to do?
All right,
let's redraw the Matrix.
So here's the game,
two zero four minus 24 zero zero four audit,
not audit.
And
Hey,
honestly,
or cheat.
All right.
So here's our new payoffs and let's ask the question with this new fine in place
that we've raised the fine,
okay
to being caught,
not paying your taxes in the long run.
Once things have worked their way back into equilibrium again,
right?
After a few years,
do we expect American tax paying compliance to go up or to go down or what do we
expect?
What do we think's going to happen?
So who thinks it's going to go up?
Who thinks is going to go down there?
Was going to stay the same?
Here's a painting here and these are the parents were staining.
Not really to have state.
You have to have just so vote here.
Well how are we gonna figure this out?
How we're going to figure out what's going to happen to compliance.
What happens
to tax compliance?
Pectin plant that that was our,
that was our p no it wasn't.
Sorry.
It was our,
it was our kid.
It's our cue,
right?
Well anyway,
we're going to figure this out just to work it out.
So let's work out the new Q.
An equilibrium.
All right,
let's do this.
Alright,
so to find out the new Q and equilibrium,
once again,
we're going to have to look at the auditor's payoffs and the auditor's payoffs.
If they audit,
they're going to get to Q plus four one minus Q,
and if they don't audit,
they're going to get four Q plus zero one minus Q four Q part zero one minus Q
two Q plus four one minus Q.
And if the auditor is indifferent to that mixing,
it must still be the case that these are equal.
And I want to ask you a question where have you seen that equation before?
Yeah,
it's still there.
I didn't delete it.
It's the same equation I said top down.
Is that right?
From the orders,
his points of view,
given the payoffs to the officers,
nothing has changed.
So the tax compliance rates that makes the auditor exactly indifference between
audit and your parents and not auditing your parents is still exactly the same
as it was before.
Cut Two thirds in equilibrium tax compliance hasn't changed at all.
Miss Heather again,
right?
The policy was we're going to double the fines for being caught cheating and in
equilibrium.
It made absolutely no difference whatsoever to the equilibrium tax compliance
rate.
All right.
How?
Why did it make no difference?
Why did it make a difference?
Well,
let's just,
let's have a Techie,
I'm sorry,
in the nurse and then a better,
more intuitive upset.
The techie answers this.
What determines the equilibrium tax compliance rate?
What determines the equilibrium mix for the column player is what is the rose
payoffs,
right?
What determines the equilibrium mix for the column player are the Rose Pay.
I'll row players' payoffs.
We didn't change the role players payoffs.
So when north is going to change the equilibrium mix for the column player,
say again,
we changed one of the payoffs for the column player,
but the columns,
players,
equilibrium mix depends on the row players' payoffs and we haven't changed the
rope hires payoffs,
so we won't change the equilibrium compliance rate,
the equilibrium mix by the column player.
What will have changed here?
What will have changed in the new equilibrium?
So we've pretty much established that people are cheating as much as they were
before and equally Rehmann roll.
Can I get Henry here and w wait for the mic.
Wait.
Say again.
The probability of audit will have the problems of audit will have changed.
What's going to change is not the queue,
but the p the prevalence with which you're audited is going to change in this
marvel.
All right.
As check heads to find the new P,
I need to look at the tax payers pay offs and the taxpayers pay offs are now
zero.
Uh,
if they,
sorry,
if they pay their taxes honestly,
then they get zero and if they cheats they get minus 20 with probability p and
four with privacy,
one minus P
if they're mixing,
if some of them are paying and some of the knock,
this must be the same.
And uh,
being more careful than I was last time.
I hope this gives me a 24 P is equal to four or p equals
a sick.
All right,
so the audit rate has gone down from two seventh to one sick.
I'm guessing that probably wasn't the goal of the policy or there isn't
necessarily a bad thing.
Right?
There is some,
there is some benefit for society here cause audits are costly both to do for
the auditor and the unpleasant to be audited.
So the fact we've managed to lower the audit rates from two sevenths to a sick
is a good thing.
All right.
But we didn't manage to raise the compliance rate.
I don't wanna make this model to literally cause it's,
you know,
it's just,
it's just a toy model.
But nevertheless,
let's try and draw out some lessons from this model.
All right,
so here what we did was we changed the payoff to cheating.
We made it,
made it worse,
right?
But a different kind of change is we could have changed,
sorry,
we changed the pay off negatively to being caught cheating.
Right?
But a different change we could have done is we could have left the minus 10 in
place and we could have raised the pay off to cheating and not getting course.
We could have left this 10 in place and change this for,
let's say to a six or an eight.
All right.
We had increased the benefits to cheating.
If you're not caught,
what would that have done in equilibrium?
What?
What would that have done in equilibrium?
So I claim once again,
that would have done in equilibrium to the probability of people paying their
taxes,
but that would have done what to the audit rate.
The audit rate would've gone up.
You could have an audit rate would have gone up.
Okay.
All right.
Let's tell that story a second,
right?
So rich people,
people who will well paid have a little bit more to gain from cheating on their
taxes.
If they're not course there's more money at speak.
All right.
So my colleagues were finance professors in the business school have more money
on that to,
on their tax returns than I do.
So in principle,
they gain more if they cheese.
All right.
Does that mean that they cheat more than me and he could have room?
No,
it doesn't mean that they cheat more than many clever and what does it mean?
Okay.
It means they get audited more often,
right?
And equilibrium.
Richer people aren't necessarily going to cheat more,
but they all going to get audited more.
And that's true,
right?
The,
the,
the federal audit rights are designed so they audit the rich more than they
audit the poor.
Again,
it's not because they think the rich are inherently less honest or the poor are
inherently more on us or anything like that.
It's simply that the games to cheating and not getting caught a bigger if you're
rich,
so you need to audit more to push back into equilibrium.
All right?
Now
suppose we did in fact want to use the policy of raising fines to push down,
to push out the compliance,
right?
To push down cheating.
Okay.
How would we change the law?
Because I suppose when we want to,
we want to get,
we want to raise the fines for cheating.
We don't make people cheating,
so we raise the fines,
but we're worried about this result.
But worried about this result that didn't push up compliance rates.
How can we change the law or change the incentives in the game?
So it actually would change compliance rates.
What could we do?
Yeah,
auditing two,
four from two to four.
Good,
good,
good.
If we want to change the compliance rates,
we should have changed the payoff to the auditor.
Okay.
All right.
The problem with the way the oldest her is paid here is that the auditor is paid
more if they manage to catch people.
Right.
But audit it's a costly.
All right.
And the problem with that is when you raise the file on the other side,
all that,
all that happens is it's the auditor's audit less often and equilibrium.
So if you want to get a higher compliance rate,
one thing you could do is rate is changed.
The payoff to the auditor to make orders saying less costly for them or making
or making,
catching people,
uh,
nice stuff for them.
Give them a reward or you could simply take it out of game three altogether.
You could enforce,
you'd have a congressional rule law that sets the audit rates outside of
equilibrium.
And that's been much discussed in Congress over the last five years.
Somebody is sitting audit rates as it were exogenously by Congress.
Why might that not be a great idea?
Leaving aside economic theory for it,
even just like game theory,
why might it not be a great idea to have congress at the audit rates rather than
rather than a summer office?
Yeah,
they're going to lower the audit rate.
Right?
So,
so the,
the,
the lady in the front is saying a lot of congressmen or rather rich.
So maybe they have particular incentives here.
I don't,
I don't want,
I can put it a particular political stones here,
but it could be whatever side of the political spectrum you guys this on.
All right.
It could be that you might not trust Congress to get this right.
Right.
You might think they're going to come political considerations going on in
Congress other than just having an efficient tax system.
All right.
Okay,
so what do I want to draw out as lessons here?
The big lessons from this class are there are three different ways to think
about randomization and equilibrium or out of equilibrium.
One is it's genuinely randomisation.
Another is it could be something about people's beliefs.
And a third way and a very important way is it could be telling us something
about the proportion of people who are doing something in society,
in this case,
the proportion of people who are paying tax.
All right,
and a second important lesson I want to draw out here beyond just finding
equilibria,
right?
Two other things we drew out today.
One lesson was when you're checking equilibria,
checking mixed strategy equilibria,
you only have to check for pure strategy deviations.
Be careful.
You have to check for all possible pure strategy deviations,
not just the pure strategies that were involved in the mix.
If the guy has seven strategies and there's only mixing on too,
you have to remember to check the other five.
All right.
And the third lesson I want to draw up today is because of the way equilibria
work with mixed strategy,
equilibrium of work,
if I change the column players' payoffs,
it changes the role players,
equilibrium mix.
And if I change the role players pay offs,
it changes the column players equilibrium mix.
Next time we're going to pick up this idea that mixed strategies can be about
proportions of people playing things and take it to a totally different setting,
namely evolution.
So on Wednesday,
we'll start talking about evolution.